he goes by many names him the deliverer
God Slayer avenging hand of light
whatever you call him Adam Warlock is
one of the most impressive specimens in
the Galaxy so Will Poulter the actor who
plays him had to put in the work Adam
Warlock in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3.
um look at your face right it's a lot
this is a lot building a superhero
physique is an unbelievably grueling
process bulking and shaping up is hard
work for anyone especially when it means
transforming a comedic actor like Ryan
Reynolds into Deadpool or the diminutive
Natalie Portman into the Mighty Thor
will poulter's superhero upgrade was no
exception and the actor has opened up
about the challenges involved in his
rigid routine in an interview with the
independent Poulter mentioned how his
whole life essentially became training
consisting of a lot of gym work and a
very very specific diet he also
explained the sacrifices involved in
spending so much time exercising and
eating saying the whole social side of
your life has to take a back seat I'm in
a routine that is so rigid that being
able to go out for dinner with friends
is not some thing I've been able to do
clearly the process is as much about
what you can't do as it is about what
you do
piecing together the timeline of his
involvement with Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 it's clear that Poulter wasted no
time in beginning to bulk up the first
news of Poulter being cast in the role
came on October 11 2021 via deadline and
was confirmed the same day by director
James Gunn within two short days the
actor had already revealed that he was
getting in shape in an interview with
flip your wig on October 13th Poulter
said that he had started the process of
physically becoming Warlock and it
showed even then poulter's arms were
visibly larger than normal and though he
humbly attributed the added muscle to
simply trying to keep busy during the
pandemic it's almost a certainty that
those biceps were a product of his
training given that deadline reported
Poulter was shortlisted for the role
around two months prior it's likely that
he was working out before the world even
knew he had landed the role
the majority of poulter's responses when
asked about his Newfound physique have
been about eating instead of exercising
he told the independent that his
trainers kept him on a very very
specific diet he explained its
quantities of food you wouldn't
necessarily want to ingest and other
times not enough food I've gone through
a series of different diets over the
last few months though he didn't get
much more specific due to Marvel's
policy of being as polter put it all
Secret Squirrel he at least confirmed
that he was given separate diets for
building mass then cutting fat than
maintaining weight his interview with GQ
went much the same way Poulter avoided
any specifics about his diet but did
bring a protein shake with him for the
10 a.m interview which reporter Ben
Allen noted speaks volumes
yes I love chicken nuggets I was on a
diet where I probably would have had to
take the batter off like I would have
been that person like a lot of high
profile actors Will Poulter is always
working so most of the information about
his warlock workouts has come in the
midst of interviews about the Hulu
series Dope Sick according to Poulter
however when it came time to become Adam
Warlock he set everything else aside and
made the transformation his life he
asserted to GQ that warlock was his only
occupation at that moment he then told
variety it was actually my job to just
kind of train and eat he made it clear
that to a large extent he shut himself
off from the world and just focused on
working out consuming calories and
building muscle mass for someone whose
career potentially enables them to take
on multiple projects at the same time
and earn some major cash from each his
commitment to focusing on solely one job
is admirable
probably the most common sentiment that
Poulter has expressed when discussing
his metamorphosis into Adam Warlock is
how much Studio support he had
throughout and how grateful he is for it
essentially every time he's asked about
his newly bulging biceps he cites the
financial physical and mental support
that Marvel and its Affiliates gave him
throughout the process worked with an
amazing team of people who you know
really took care of kind of my mental
health through the process of going
through all the physical sort of
challenges he told us weekly I was
incredibly well supported and couldn't
have had more help in the respect of the
diet and the training that was required
that was key certainly not something I
went away and did on my own He also
mentioned his trainers often saying they
curated his workouts and created his
different diet plans it's apparent that
no matter what he did he did it
alongside some of the best trainers that
Marvel could get which likely means the
best trainers anyone could get
one specific aspect of poulter's
evolution into Adam Warlock has drawn
more attention and appeared in more
headlines than any other his emphatic
assertion that mental health is more
important than anything else when
undergoing such a strenuous Endeavor in
particular one quote from his
independent interview has been at the
center of the media Focus he said the
most important thing is that your mental
and physical health has to be number one
and the aesthetic goals have to be
secondary otherwise you end up promoting
something that is unhealthy and
unrealistic that quote has drawn its
share of analysis and praise but
regardless of what anyone else believes
it's clear that falter deeply values his
mental health and went into the process
of building a new body in a thoughtful
holistic way
foreign